ça va me parle pas bon qu'est ce qui
t'arrive qu'est ce que je fais encore
c'est pas envie de keephills locaux
vides on est au moins à cinq mètres là
ça va non mais il paraît que le virus il
est un petit l'état plane et un
détecteur de narines à les retourner sur
terre on facebook que scientifiquement
non non c'est ma tante
alain voisins dans le neveu a bu un coup
avec un gars qui connaît hyper bien un
chercheur des services secrets a dans ce
cas-là activement
bon on va voir un petit peu où on en est
avec cette histoire de qu'ovide les
masques les anticorps les vaccins tout
ça mais avant on le sait depuis début
mai s'est pas inutile de le rappeler
même si maintenant ça fait quelques mois
qu'on le connaît ce virus
ça reste un virus très récent sur lequel
tout ce qu'on sait ça évolue très
rapidement
ça évolue même pratiquement de jour en
jour parce que en matière de science la
vérité d'un jour elle est contredite le
lendemain par une nouvelle étude des
faits nouveaux des nouvelles
observations et c'est donc on se faire
un petit état des lieux sur ce qu'on
sait aujourd'hui mais ça va encore
bouger ça c'est sûr donc ce qu'on va se
dire aujourd'hui c'est pas définitif
mais avant d'entrer dans le vif du sujet
on va commencer par répondre à la
question cruciale est ce qu'on doit dire
le coc vide
l'arrco vide
[Musique]
le que vides ou la co vide s usages qui
doit prévaloir
ou doit-on se ranger à l'avis émis par
l'académie française
tous les experts de dtc se sont penchés
sur cette épineuse question ils ont
rendu leur rapport
et ils sont unanimes sans équivoque
la réponse est les steaks
merci de votre attention voilà bon ceci
dit petit point lexical quand même
coronavirus alors ça c'est le nom de la
famille à laquelle appartient le virus
qui est responsable de la pandémie
actuelle et cette famille là on la
connaît depuis des années et même
sûrement pas mal à avoir déjà chopé un
accord aux navires us un hiver et c'est
passé pour une grippe sarr skov 2 ça
c'est le nom du virus de la famille des
coronavirus donc qui est responsable de
la pandémie actuelle ça veut dire
coronavirus 2 du syndrome respiratoire
aigu sévère
pour mémoire le sar score 1 1
si vous voulez c'est celui qui a été
responsable de l'épidémie de sras en
2003 et qu'ovide 19
c'est le nom de la maladie provoquée par
sare skov 2 le virus de la famille des
coronavirus voilà maintenant qu'on est
d'accord là dessus on va prendre les
points qui posent problème ou qui pose
question un par un elle sera plus simple
les masques
ouais autant commencer par le gros
morceau tout de suite alors dans
certaines régions le port du masque est
devenu obligatoire dans tous les lieux
publics y compris dans la rue et ça
énerve les gens pour plein de raisons
d'abord parce que ils trouvent ça
pénible mais en vrai on s'y fait quand
même
ensuite parce que ils ont peur de
manquer d'oxygène alors non en fait les
masses qui sont prévus pour qu'on puisse
respirer correctement avec vous pouvez
demander aux soignants comporte toute la
journée depuis des années au bloc
opératoire par exemple et puis parce
qu'il ya des gens qui n'aiment pas qu'on
les oblige à faire quelque chose c'est
sûrement les mêmes qui veulent pas
mettre leur ceinture de sécurité
mais il ya aussi un truc qui revient
souvent c'est le oui mais le
gouvernement
il nous manque parce que quand il en
avait pas des masques il nous disait que
ça sert
et ça ça mérite qu'on s'y attarde un
petit peu alors je vais pas vous parler
de la com
gouvernement j'en sais pas plus que vous
là dessus mais on peut parler de
l'efficacité des masques par contre
d'abord c'est vrai que les masques on
utilise ils sont pas efficace à 100%
parce qu'ils filtrent pas 100 % des
particules surtout si elles sont très
petites comme celle du virus mais l'idée
c'est de diminuer le plus possible les
risques de contamination donc on peut se
dire que c'est quand même mieux que rien
même si c'est pas 100% ensuite c'est
vrai aussi qu'il n'ya pas d'étude
scientifique à proprement parler qui
démontre que faire porter un masque à
tout le monde c'est efficace mais avec
toutes les nouvelles données qu'on a sur
le port du masque depuis le début de la
pandémie puisque on emporte partout dans
le monde maintenant et en se basant sur
des observations c'est à dire pas des
études scientifiques à proprement parler
effectivement mais quand même on en
arrive à la conclusion que porter un
masque
ça diminue quand même très certainement
les risques de contamination
à condition de continuer à respecter
toutes les autres règles sanitaires
comme la distanciation physique ou le
lavage des mains parce que ça ça a fait
la preuve scientifique de son efficacité
le masque c'est complément mais surtout
pour que ce soit efficace faut pas juste
mettre un masque
il faut s'en servir correctement il faut
bien le maître déjà après il faut plus y
toucher il faut pas le fourrer dans son
sac le ressortir pour leur maître etc
sinon comme potentiellement il est
contaminé par des gouttelettes bas on en
fous partout et c'est contre productif
donc on va retenir trois trucs non c'est
pas efficace à 100 % mais rien ne l'est
jamais vraiment pourra pas se mentir
et puis l'idée c'est de diminuer au
maximum les risques de contamination
donc même en imaginant que c'est
efficace jusqu'à 70 % comme mesure c'est
toujours mieux que zéro pour cent il ya
des règles à respecter pour que ce soit
efficace
on en a déjà parlé mais je vais vous
remettre des liens dans la description
et surtout ce qui est important se
rappeler c'est que on le porte pour
protéger les autres au cas où on est
infecté sans le savoir et les autres le
porte pour nous protéger nous du coup
pour que tout le monde soit protégé il
faut que tout le monde le porte
la distanciation physique alors la
distanciation avec le lavage des mains
c'est les trucs les plus efficaces pour
se protéger mais là aussi les
connaissances évoluent donc les
consignes aussi ça veut pas dire que
c'est n'importe quoi ça veut dire que
les
l'étude apporte de nouvelles infos donc
il faut s'adapter
au début on disait un maître puis un
mètre cinquante et là on commence à
arriver autour de 2 m alors pour les
contacts prolongés
bien sûr mais il ya des études qui ont
aussi trouvé des traces du virus en
suspension dans l'air ça veut dire que
ils circulent il se déplace mais
attention ça veut pas forcément dire
qu'il est contaminé
il peut y en avoir en suspension mais
pas forcément assez pour qu'il infecte
un humain c'est comme la durée de vie du
virus sur les objets il faut une
certaine quantité de virus en bon état
pour qu'il ya un risque de contamination
donc au bout d'un certain temps même si
on retrouve du virus sur un objet il est
plus en assez grande quantité et il est
plus en assez bon état pour nous
infectés bref
concrètement oui il ya le masque mais on
continue à se tenir à distance les uns
des autres dans les magasins au bureau
et dans tous les cas où on est au
contact les uns des autres de façon
prolongée et on se lave les mains
régulièrement et tous les autres jess
marièrent aussi la reprise de l'épidémie
alors déjà je vous propose qu'on laisse
tomber ses histoires de premières vagues
ou de deuxième vague personne est
vraiment d'accord là dessus toute façon
ça change pas grand chose
ce qui est sûr c'est que avec le
déconfinement et puis la réouverture des
bars et des restos puis des vacances
d'été le nombre de cas ils augmentent
d'un côté c'est logique c'est normal
qu'ils en aient plus que quand personne
ne sortait de chez soi d'un autre côté
c'est flippant
concrètement au moment du des
confirmands on était à peu près à 500
nouveaux cas par jour
c'est resté à peu près stable jusqu'à mi
juillet et puis ça a commencé à
augmenter progressivement pour passer à
1000 2000 3000 nouveaux cas par jour
jusqu'à la mi-août et on en est arrivé à
des journées à cinq six sept mille cas
positifs par jour à la fin du mois
d'août
mais dans le même temps le nombre
d'hospitalisations il a augmenté
beaucoup moins vite en tout cas pas du
tout dans les mêmes proportions et le
nombre de décès il est resté
relativement stable et faut garder à
l'esprit que le nombre de tests de
dépistage
il a énormément augmenté début avril on
en était à peu près à 150 milles par
semaine fin août on en était à 900
milles par semaine donc plus on teste de
personnes plus on trouve deux personnes
infectées c'est logique les experts
pensent qu'il ya moins de personnes
infectées en france aujourd'hui qu'avant
le confinement
mais attention et on a quand même sans
doute plus que début juillet oui parce
que début juillet il y avait 1 % des
personnes testées qui était positive et
c'est passé à 3 % fin août
donc ça augmente moins que ce que les
chiffes pourrait laisser craindre mais
ça augmente quand même et siham ans
d'hospitalisation et moins de décès
c'est aussi probablement
mais là encore on peut faire que des
suppositions parce que les personnes à
risque et les personnes fragiles sont
mieux protégés il ya plein d'autres
explications possibles et il faut pas
céder à la panique parce que
manifestement les choses sont moins
graves que ce qu on pourrait craindre vu
les chiffres mais quand même le r0 le
fameux vers zéro le taux de reproduction
du virus
il serait selon certaines estimations
repassé au-dessus de 1 et il faudrait
qu'il soit en dessous pour endiguer
l'épidémie
donc on en revient à ce fameux équilibre
à préserver il faut à tout prix éviter
que les hôpitaux soient saturés et il
faut anticiper parce que l'on sait que à
partir du moment où on met une nouvelle
règle sanitaire en place il ya un
décalage avant qu'elle soit efficace
surtout que l'été c'est bientôt fini
et du coup on va se retrouver de plus en
plus dans des lieux fermés les anticorps
et l'immunité
je sais pas si vous vous souvenez au
début de l'épidémie on parlait d'
immunité collective y avait certains
pays qui avaient décidé de rien faire de
laisser circuler le virus en se disant
qu'au bout d'un certain temps il y
aurait suffisamment de personnes
immunisées pour que l'épidémie s'arrête
tout seul c'était pas du tout idéaux
dans l'absolu comme idée ça se défend
des complètement mais ils ont quand même
vite changé d'avis parce qu'ils sont
rendu compte que ça marchait pas très
bien et ils ont bien fait de changer
d'avis parce que on sait depuis que nos
anticorps ceux qui sont censés nous
protéger contre le virus et durent pas
très longtemps
cet été à hong kong il ya des médecins
qui ont publié sur un cas de ré
infection celui d'un patient qui avait
été testé positif et qu'avec déclaré lee
co vide
et puis qui a été de nouveau testé
positif plus de quatre mois après le cas
de ce patient et les analyses qui ont
été faites sur ces premiers prélèvements
virologiques et ses premières sérologie
que les médecins avaient mis de côté et
ce qu'ils ont fait au moment de la
réinfection ça nous a appris deux choses
d'abord les analyses génétiques qui ont
été faites sur le virus de la première
infection et sur celui de sa deuxième
infections ça a montré qu'ils n'avaient
pas le même génome donc c'était deux
souches différentes et ensuite on a
découvert que quatre mois après il
n'avait pas d'anticorps et ça c'est un
truc qu'on connaît maintenant
d'après ce qu'on sait au moment où je
tourne cette vidéo on estime que les
anticorps ils sont plus efficaces ou de
2 à 3 mois chez la majorité des gens et
qui peuvent même disparaître ou en tout
cas devenir indétectable
du coup ça pose pas mal de questions sur
les vaccins alors déjà que dès qu'on
parle de vaccins il y en a quelques-uns
qui se met à saigner du nez et avoir
tout mais alors si en plus il faut
refaire un accent tous les deux trois
mois ça va être compliqué pour le moment
les chercheurs il reste confiant il
explique notamment qu'il n'y a pas que
les anticorps qui protège contre le
virus
mais ça ça mériterait une vidéo à part
entière donc on va probablement reparler
dans quelques temps
de toute façon très semblablement le
vaccin sera pas avant 2021 et encore
mais ce qu'il faut retenir c'est même si
vous avez déjà été testés positifs et
qu'ils ont continué à respecter les
gestes barrières et si vous n'avez
jamais été testés positifs aussi bien
sûr on n'a qu'à dire que tout le monde
respecte les gestes barrières comme ça
c'est bien voilà dtc c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui plus que jamais prenez soin
de vous et prenez soin des autres
protégez-vous et protéger les autres
mettez vous bien quand même et surtout
portez vous bien